crunch berries crunch berries peanut
butter Catholic okay that's as close
second it's dinnertime it's that time
all right
107 degrees too high for the date today
102 are normal we have been
above-average lately and we're keeping
that trend going for now that's gonna
change though by the time we get to your
weekend 85 for the overnight low that's
a warm start to our Thursday morning
let's get to some neighborhoods some 103
there northwest neighborhoods though
we're not gonna leave you out you're
currently hundred and five for Aliante
104 for Sky Canyon and Centennial Hills
yeah we're calling you out 106 in
downtown 108 sunrise mountain 106 Green
Valley and Henderson hundred four and
Henderson other neighborhoods look at
this Rhodes Ranch in the southwest part
of the valley you're at 103 mountains
edge also in that Southern Highlands a
little further south you're currently at
102 along with Seven Hills 104 up 102
for Boulder City Laughlin 108 and we're
at a hundred and thirteen out there and
Death Valley it is hot out there in Inyo
County right now it's just to the north
this is not Las Vegas we're down here
but just to the north this will get some
thunderstorms that are popping up
they're dying out a little bit but
they're sending some wind that we're
seeing outside right now and that could
continue through this evening as well
Futurecast does show tomorrow we could
get a chance of some of these to pop up
in the mountains and some of these could
stray into the valley now here's the
deal with these okay there's not a lot
of moisture to work with the low levels
of the atmosphere still remains dry so
if we get anything and they'll be really
gusty winds with these storms now we
could see some also light light shower
activity or even just sprinkles with it
but really this will be mainly on the
mountains that could stream the valley
specifically tomorrow later on in the
afternoon or early on the afternoon and
tomorrow night looks good we're clear on
Saturday winds also back again for this
evening little gusty at times for the
western portions of the valley and then
those winds will die off a little
tomorrow morning and then become a
little breezy again in the afternoon
especially if we get those thunderstorms
and a fire up they'll give us what we
call those outflow winds across the
valley so bless your Kirsten what
Saturday we picked that up on the Mike
that's how wild that was all right
for Sunday though those winds will be
big-time alright we're tracking those
winds for Sunday we'll get those gusts
up to 40 to 45 80 overnight warm and
mostly clear little gusty at times from
those outflow winds from those nearby
storms near high tomorrow 103 Sun and
clouds breezy times Mountain
thunderstorms a good chance for that
here are forecasted highs around the
valley for tomorrow hundred two for
North Las Vegas along with the lakes 106
sunrise mountain we're looking at 104
prop 102 for Boulder City here's a look
at your extended forecast now wind on
Sunday big winds along with gusts
possibly along with Monday's winds and
the temperatures dropping to the 90s on
Monday that is your most accurate
forecast we will be right back